bonsoir bonsoir luthérienne nous sommes
toujours en compagnie de roland dumas
jean françois copé
michel cymes
accueillons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir dalila bonsoir
dalila je précise que c'est vous qui
avait demandé qu'on ne cite pas votre
nom de famille évidemment alors avant de
commencer une question d'ordre pratique
n'est pas un peu chaud là dessous
qu'est ce qu'ils me prouvent vous n'êtes
pas en train de me tirer la langue
[Musique]
dalila re bonsoir vous êtes né en
octobre
1987 à dijon vous avez 22 ans votre
maman qui est française a vécu un temps
en algérie et a voulu garder une trace
de son passage là-bas en appelant ses
deux filles jumelles dalila et salwa des
prénoms qui vous rattache à un père qui
ne vous a pas reconnu elle a voulu et
que par la suite heures
[Musique]
on lui reproche pas de nous avoir
rappelé par un prénom français d'accord
vous avez vécu toutes les trois dans un
hlm de la banlieue de dijon vous avez
été scolarisés dans le public et ensuite
dans un lycée privé catholique jusqu'à
un bac pro en bureautique mais ensuite
comme vous étiez bonne élève vous êtes
allé à la fac de droit de dijon votre
mère mais pas spécialement de religion
mais elle a toujours refusé de lui
servir du port à table
cela vous intrigue et vers l'âge de 13
ans vous commencez à vous poser des
questions et votre mère vous répond un
petit peu comme pour votre prénom c'est
pour pas que vous me le reprocher plus
tard mais ça alors vous comprenez pas
bien vous allez acheter un exemplaire du
coran un livre sur les femmes du
prophète mahomet et vous apprenez tout
seul les raisons pour lesquelles vous ne
devez pas manger de porc oui
ma mère n'est même pas musulmane bah oui
vous comprenez même même pas pourquoi
elle est plutôt des listes oui a dit
qu'elle prend en dieu mais elle ne se
rattache à aucune religion ouais donc
donc on a commencé à apprendre et à
notre manière de vivre d'être d'être
lorsqu'on a appris la religion on s'est
dit mais c'est nous c'est l'autre façon
de penser ouais donc m'assurer molle a
commencé à prendre à la religion et on
l'a on l'a aimé on va aimer jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ils ont appris à
devenir être à devenir musulmane et être
une musulmane parler tant que française
voilà chose qui est à l'heure actuelle
et jean les politiciens ils veulent pas
comprendre ouais à partir de là toutes
vos économies vos salaires à l'âge de 16
ans vous travaillez dans un hôtel passe
dans l'achat de livre d'initiation au
coran et alors
à un moment vous porter le foulard donc
pendant six mois mais vous réalisez
qu'en fait le véritable
voile islamique c'est le voile intégral
tu voulais pas passer par le foulard
parce que je savais très bien que la
base le voile islamique c'est un voile
et non
ensuite j'ai appris par la suite que les
écoles
je leur ai dit qu'ils samic
son divergent sur la façon de porter le
voile certains disent qu'on doit voir le
visage mais c'est la minorité et la
majorité 10 points doit revoir ou de
rien voir mais pas les yeux et est ce
qu'on pouvait nous dire pourquoi dans la
religion musulmane
la femme doit se couvrir autant c'est
une prescription religieuse la vérité la
vérité elle est qu' il ya des règles on
y suit on se voit pas question d'accord
oui mais ce câble la religion catholique
hop on mange du poisson vendredi
alors vous commencez à porter ce voile
intégral en fin de troisième donc dans
la cour de récréation mais pas en cours
c'était un coup les jeux catholique il
motorisés mais arrivé en classe et je me
dévoile est d'accord alors aujourd'hui
quand vous vous promenez comme ça dans
la rue qu'elle regarde les gens portent
sur vous d'aller là bas c'est vraiment
important et en même temps une même jour
à dijon il y avait aucune femme voilée
je veux dire à part quelques unes en
fleurs sinon c'était pire c'était mal vu
ouais on était des femmes soumises ont
été des femmes déjà mariée pour la
plupart il me plaît madame alors que
j'avais 17 ans ouais donc voila mais les
gens se sont habitués
est ce qu'elle est ce que les gens
portent sur vous un regard inquisiteur
est ce que je me pose des questions
ouais ils posent des questions mais
maintenant ça s'est dissipé un petit peu
d'accord beaucoup même vous vous sentez
que ça va mieux là vous êtes mieux la
mise plus le temps passe en fait avant
les gens dans la rue j'ai subi des
agressions j'ai subi des insultes
maintenant il a encore dit mme berger -
est-ce que vous avez été agressé
verbalement verbalement et physiquement
qu'est-ce qui vous disent quand ils vous
agressent verbalement par exemple ma
presse a rejoint le les opinions des
messieurs copie c'est à dire femme
soumise après des insultes et bien y'a
plus
bien plus bien plus grosse mais ces
liens sont quelques uns à voulez vous
être anglais we par celle qui m'a dit on
n'est pas les antennes d'histoire et la
misère moi elle m'a prise par la gorge
mais jeudi on n'est pas le résistant la
france je suis française oui et je
porterai se voyaient même si tu
m'agresses j'ai le garde et j'ai gardé
cinq ans près j'ai toujours et la
personne qui vous a agressé physiquement
qui a essayé de vous être anglais
c'était un homme une femme d'une
quarantaine d'années même pas porté
plainte ouais je veux dire j'ai porté ce
voyage je savais à quoi m'attendre alors
ce qui était assez extraordinaire
effectivement c'est que les gens qui
vous voient comme ça vous croit soumises
obligé de porter ce voile à cause d'un
homme soit un père soit un frère soit un
mari est en fait non personne c'est ça
qu'il faut dire quand même parce que là
ça pose le problème d'une façon un peu
différente effectivement personne ne
vous oblige à vous habiller comme ça
qu'il faut le dire c'est votre décision
deux citoyennes françaises voilà j'étais
très importance alors pour vous le voile
n'est pas un handicap aujourd'hui
puisque à la faculté on a le droit de
porter le voile tir dans les collèges et
lycées c'est interdit mais à la faculté
en a le droit a donc fait vos études de
droit simplement vos professeurs vous
demande de vous dévoiler pour les
examens c'est bien s'avérer là et j'ai
passé des examens il nous dit on vous
accueillir pour ce que c'est vous nous
mêmes c'est même pas la peine de vous
dévoiler son plan religieux vous n'êtes
pas extrémiste je te passe à la fif vous
n'êtes pas je ne suis aucun courant
secteur ouais
en gros quand on voit là vous ce que
vous pensez en fait c'est que les filles
françaises aujourd'hui cherche à
ressembler à celle qu'on voit dans
cyclades story et pour vous c'est un peu
l'abomination ça c'est à dire la
marchandisation du corps de la femme
pour moi ça représente vraiment la fin
de france est oui ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
veut des les
mots significatifs c'est la femme
française et et moi j'amène ma vie je
serai comme ça
on vous verra jamais dans secret story
alors vous dites ce sont les dictatures
qui impose aux gens comment s'habiller
oui et comme la france n'est pas une
dictature on ne peut pas m'imposer
comment s'habiller chez moi ça
représente vraiment mal les projets de
monsieur copé représente vraiment mal un
pays démocratique vraiment pas ouais je
sois à se mêler de la religion vraiment
pas mais on se met le panier des
religions en plus vous n'avez aucune
science en matière de volume de religion
vous ne savez pas et je recherchais
recherché c'est quoi la vérité dans la
religion et après vous pouvez discuter
avec des filles qui portent ce voile à
ceux ci étant dalila et accordé des
millions de musulmans qui vivent leur
islam en france sans porter le voile
intégral chacun ses convictions ceci
étant chaque pays a son fonctionnement
par exemple en arabie saoudite
si on veut construire une église en
arabie saoudite on peut pas on pourrait
aussi penser qu'en france tout le monde
suit une certaine vague comme en arabie
saoudite puis contre le système et
saoudiens d'accord au système soutient
et contre tous les systèmes dé payer un
beau bijou te dire la femme la femme là
je suis d'accord la femme elle est
soumise on impose à des fins qui sont pq
qui peuvent ne pas même pas croire en
dieu à porter un voile elles n'ont pas
voulu
donc vous ce que vous dites là c'est que
vous êtes contre cette police religieuse
les types qui ont des petites baguettes
comme ça dans la rue qui embête les
femmes qui sont venues aux mains vitry
contre ça mais l'hystérie d'accord alors
jean-françois
vous avez pris la tête un petit peu de
la campagne anti burqa en tous les cas
vous allez pris de vitesse la mission
parlementaire qui doit donner ses
conclusions fin janvier vous avez des
positions qui sont même plus dur je
dirais que celle de brice hortefeux qui
lui est pour l'interdiction
uniquement dans les services publics et
vous aller jusqu'à prôner une amende de
750 euros pour s'habiller comme ça oui
je dois dire
vous écoutant que cela renforcer des
convictions qui sont les miennes et je
me permets de vous dire pas simplement
les miennes je voudrais d'ailleurs vous
dire vous avez plusieurs fois employé le
terme d' insulte je n'ai pas du tout le
sentiment en prenant cette position
d'insulter qui que ce soit si vous
disiez tout à l'heure en me regardant
puisque en fait c'est la seule chose que
nous pouvons faire c'est échanger des
regards là où moi je pense que le
premier contact entre deux personnes
avant même le regard c'est le sourire
moi je peux vous sourirez que
malheureusement je ne sais jamais si
vous répondez à mon sourire mais en tout
cas sachez une chose c'est que tout à
l'heure vous m'avez dit monsieur copé
vous ne connaissez pas la religion
connaissait la et voyez les règles avant
de juger moi je voudrais vous dire que
la particularité de la france comme
d'autres pays c'est d'être une
démocratie et c'est d'être une
démocratie laïque qu'est ce que c'est la
laïcité c'est pas du tout la négation
des religions c'est le fait que chacun
puisse exercer son culte s'ils le
souhaitent dans le respect de celui de
l'autre et moi personnellement comme
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de français
parce que c'est ce qui a fait ne creuset
de notre pays je suis évidemment très
respectueux du fait que chacun
appartiennent à une communauté
religieuse
associatifs politiques mais à une
condition c'est que les règles de la
communauté soient subordonnées
subordonnée aux règles de la république
pas égal aux règles de la république
et parmi les règles de la république il
y à celle du vivre ensemble or pour que
l'on puisse vivre ensemble il faut que
l'on connaisse l'identité de l'autre et
la première élément de l'identité c'est
le visage et donc il faut pas qu'ils
aient de doute là dessus c'est pas le
voile qui est en cause c'est le fait
d'avoir le visage
intégralement dissimulé parce que du
coup il n'ya plus d'identité et pour moi
le problème il est là parce que au-delà
de votre personne il y a en réalité une
double difficulté le premier c'est la
question du respect des femmes et la
seconde c'est la question de la sécurité
et madame moi je voudrais vous dire avec
respect
qu'on ne peut pas accepter que dans une
société comme la nôtre il y à une
situation dans laquelle un enseignant
puisse remettre un enfant à la sortie de
l'école à une personne dont il ne voit
pas le visage de la même manière on ne
peut pas banaliser le phénomène dans
lequel dans une vie en société une
partie des gens choisir et au quotidien
d'avoir le visage complètement dissimulé
donc méconnaissable savait par exemple
que le pèlerinage de la mecque vous le
savez sans doute le voile intégral est
interdit j'ai consulté le président du
conseil français du culte musulman
il a été auditionné par la mission
parlementaire il a été reçu par les
députés ump j'étais présent il nous a
dit c'est dans les minutes du texte que
ça n'était pas le port du voile intégral
une prescription religieuse pour moi le
voile intégral le voile intégral pour
moi ça n'est pas une question religieuse
je me pose à toute stigmatisation j'ai
été choqué par le débat sur les minarets
pour cette raison là le véritable sujet
ça n'est surtout pas de stigmatiser
telle ou telle communauté la cagoule
dans les manifestations et d'actes mans
d'accord moi par contre il est hors de
question de banaliser ce phénomène
permettez moi de vous dire s'il vous
plaît que en france ce qui représente
lisa
est en guerre je suis désolé il n'y a
aucune science déjà pour affirmer que il
en conscience quels sens il est quoi il
a été élu madame politique et oui
améliorer borno des madmoizelles excusez
moi mais c'est pas grave c'est juste à
qui j'ai non sais pas si c'est parce que
comme je me ferai tout ce que je connais
ma réunion non mais je penserai madame
de m'agresser pas je pense rien j'ai
donc ma difficulté avec vous je me
permets de vous le dire c'est que c'est
extrêmement difficile de discuter si je
puis dire d'égal à égal avec quelqu'un
dont on ne voit pas le visage j'ai
beaucoup de mal à parler avec vous je ne
vous vois pas c'est normal c'est normal
mais c'est très difficile c'est ce que
la société moderne la société organisée
la société du respect elle passe par le
fait d'une rencontre entre des visages
l'antre mais bien sûr mais vous voyez la
difficulté que j'ai à vous parler si
c'est ça la difficulté moi je vous
visage bien sûr pouvait cacher vous les
tâches et vous parlez vous avez vos
repas parce que le respect de la
personne n'est sûr que ça commence aussi
par son identité personne intelligente
bien le rapport nous allons demander à
l'ex patron du conseil constitutionnel
oui mais c'est pas si ce n'est pas dans
la constitution
malheureusement concernant la ville
alors est-ce que vous acceptez qu'elle
soit comme ça mais bruit moi je ne
trouve plus sa mission
ça veut dire h pas loin du monde et je
considère que ce qui envisage de
légiférer
sur ce sujet près d'une très grave
responsabilité parce que vous allez voir
ressurgir le même problème dans d'autres
religions par exemple pendant la
religion juive on affiche c'est vrai
dans la rue détenus qui ne sont pas les
tenues classiques et racisées ne voulait
dire avec les et le papillon le plat
foldingue la redingote noire ce qui fait
que même si vous n'allez pas d'attention
vous les reconnaissez ça peut ça peut
vous choquer demain par exemple si vous
avez une majorité qui n'est pas celle
d'aujourd'hui qui prendra une
manifestants une loi contraire pour pour
la religion juive ou toute autre
religion peu importe le principe
principe de laïcité formel c'est de ne
pas toucher aux religions ce que ce que
vous dites est pour moi aberrante
pourquoi mais pourquoi mais pourquoi
parce que le problème n'est pas de
savoir si il est des juifs pratiquants
qui ont comme vous dites des papillotes
ou bien un un ecclésiastique catholique
oui c'était sa tenue ou bien
naturellement un musulman le problème
n'est - bouddhisme le seul sujet qui
nous importe jugé bon et là c'est le
sujet la dissimulation du visage mais
qu'est ce que ça fait mal mais c'est un
élément majeur d'identité mais cultivant
soir je constate que sur ce point nous
sommes en désaccord sont en déjà je le
regrette mais je veux simplement vous
dire que pour ceux qui me condamnait un
prêt oui ce bolide inimaginable de
construire la société de demain avec des
gens qui vivent ensemble sans pouvoir
reconnaître leur visage michel je vous
écoute je suis pas d'accord avec
monsieur dumas sur le fait que on peut
porter un turban pour bon ainsi qu'on
peut porter une kippa pour un juif sans
s'en soit pas comparer avec la burqa ou
avec le voile intégral est pour moi un
voile intégral c'est une négation totale
de sa personnalité mais hélas le dessin
et le oui mais là c'est c'est un
avilissement sait on est une chaîne mais
perso je rédige alors méfiez vous chez
les 14 où on ne voit jamais le visage de
la femme était clos instauré par exemple
vous les voyez pas normal tête que dans
votre cas les chiffres peut-être que
dans votre canne c'est sur un choix
personnel mais on ne peut pas nier que
dans un grand nombre de cas c'est le
mari qui va imposer à sa fin j'ai pu
blesser personne
aucun autre homme que lui ne peut voir
ni ses mains ni son visage vous savez
très bien que ça existe dans la religion
musulmane et que pas mal de femmes
aujourd'hui on la burqa parce qu'elles
ne veulent pas choquer leurs maris et
que si l'on autorise aujourd'hui le port
de la burqa ou le port delà du voile
intégral à des femmes même qui comme
vous l'ont choisie à titre personnel est
seul en son âme et conscience d'autres
femmes pourront le faire mais imposées
par leurs maris et c'est ça qui me
choque aujourd'hui lorsqu'on me dit mais
c'est ma liberté de porter un voile
intégral il y a par exemple des libertés
qui sont interdites on n'est pas libre
de se balader totalement dénudée non on
n'est pas libre de se balader avec en
détenant des armes de la drogue il y a
évidemment des des interdictions c'est
comme ça qu'on organise une société vous
vous voyez ça ça rentre dans l'interdît
et bien oui ce n'est pas dans le domaine
des libertés se promener avec des armes
à la main ça c'est vrai vous avez raison
mais ça c'est l'ordre social mais ça n'a
rien à voir avec le comportement
vestimentaire mais c'est pas un
comportement veste ici en dissimulant
son visage on dissimule son identité
monsieur dumas je suis obligé de vous
dire dissimulant son identité au pose
des problèmes de sécurité je suis désolé
j'ai réparé est ce que tu t'es c'est
exactement le raisonnement qu'on a
connue des législateurs de vichy je me
permets de vous le dire mais si les
chiffres du match de tennis que cette
formule je le regrette parce que j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous - si
profonde et moi j'en pense et on n'a
absolument rien à voir et c'est vous qui
dites c'est ce que je pense mais vous
savez ce que c'était la législation de
vichy mais oui bien sûr elle conduisait
des hommes à la mort est évidemment et
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir
comment c'est osez vous faire des
comparaisons comme celle là parce que ce
texte-là ce tacle air devant un colisée
mais en vain demain s'inquiète avec
votre machine si c'était déjà ce père
qu'il y aura des sur ces jo nombre des
rejets mais enfin monsieur dumas vichy
s'était interdire à des hommes et des
femmes ou d'exercer des professions
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école
j'étais la conduite à des arrestations
et des déportations ça n'a rien avoir à
regretter n'allez pas m'apprendre ce
qu'était la législation
formule que nous devons gagner ses
frères randy le thème du temps bien
alors messieurs toute façon le temps
nous est malheureusement un parti dalila
je vous laisse le mot de la fin je vous
remercie d'avoir eu le courage de
témoigner parce que j'ai pas souvent vu
de femme balaie la télévision témoigné
donc comme c'était assez courageux
est-ce que vous avez un mot de
conclusion oui
concernant la sécurité je suis d'accord
avec vous toutes les femmes qui ont des
enfants qui vont chercher leurs enfants
à l'école si l'institutrice ne le
reconnaît pas elle peut très bien se
dévoiler le visage devant elle s'il ya
un contrôle au niveau de la police au
niveau des doigts il n'y a pas de
problème pour se dévoile mais dehors les
gens les passants ne pas avoir mon
visage pour quelles raisons pour quelle
raison un homme ou une femme doit voir
mon visage
de monsieur vous savez pourquoi parce
que c'est ma religion et rentre que
religieuse je dois porter ce voile là je
vois la hâte et légifèrent d'ankoro et
vous voulez vous voulez faire hulot pour
légiférer vous savez qu'en tant que
musulmane je n'ai pas je n'ai pas le
droit je n'ai pas nous de voir moi est
de respecter ma religion et de la
pratiquer comme bon leur semble sauf que
malheureusement respectant les ourlets
les prescriptions religieuses dans la
république française son subordonné au
respect des lois de la république et
désolé de vous le dire parce qu'il y à
d'autres solutions mais si vous me
parler je suis pas hors la loi des mains
il n'y a pas de lois d'intérieur vous
allez vous allez en faire une et je
serai hors la loi vous imaginez à mère
handicapée d'accord moi je vis avec ma
mère et ma soeur emporté voilà
pourraient plus sortir de chez lui plus
jamais bah écoutez moi je pense que je
me serais moi non mais madame chose le
mademoiselle je voudrais quand même
rappeler une chose c'est que l'école
nous avons eu le même débat sur les
signes ostentatoires religieux
ostentatoires à l'école et rappelez vous
qu'on avait dit la même chose et pour
autant parce que les français sont
profondément républicain profondément
respectueux de la législation il n'y a
eu absolument aucun problème
d'application de cette loi aucun
problème mais laëtitia n'a été respectée
de toutes confessions les 19 mai 2004
l'onu a jugé cette loi comme étant comme
étant la tolérance religieuse vous savez
pourquoi aussi parce qu'on respecte 0,10
gilles à écouter il me semblait qu'il y
avait de quoi elle jugé bien d'autres
exemples d'intolérance religieuse dans
le monde bien rares tous les cas merci à
tous pour ce débat tout à fait étonnant
à la télévision française
les corrections de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu